[Music]
Rachel and her fiance Brian fix your
face about the ups and downs of their
relationship to ET on lines Lord Z when
you look back at those first few weeks
after the finale how did that time have
an effect on your relationship the day
after the day that we should have been
celebrating you know being out in public
should have been like the most exciting
day but for me that was the toughest day
definitely I felt like people were
questioning my integrity my reputation
it was a lot of backlash on social media
but I think that just made us stronger
glad those days are behind us part of
the backlash Rachel's intense breakup
with Peter
neither have spoken with him since the
after the final rose special he was in
the running to be the next Bachelor but
ultimately producers picked re Lion Dyke
jr. were you relieved it wasn't Peter I
thought it was gonna be Peter I think
what's gonna be nice is that we can
watch it and just watch it and like Ari
isn't leaved to us in the three months
since the finale air the couple has only
spent a day apart brian moved from Miami
to Rachel's hometown of Dallas and he
just got his chiropractors license in
the state
I basically rented out my condo I sold
my car where are you guys out with
wedding planning and with talking about
it we talked about winter of next year
now we're talking about fall and to be
honest I could do spring she's not the
wedding planning type I talked a lot
about the bachelorette party she just
wants to get loose at the bachelorette
party that's that's her main goal and
while the couple is open to a televised
wedding they admit they totally loved
keeping their engagement on the down-low
in those months before it aired on TV
there is such a sexy aspect to like oh
you know like having secret code names
and meeting in a secret location I mean
we need to bring that back and have a
little roleplay or something hard to
hear first
you
[Music]